et voilà c'était hashtag happy la
dictature du bonheur un film
indispensable réalisé par Elisa Jadot
qui nous fait l'honneur de participer à
Z la Zone d'Éducation documentaire
bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation à vos côtés on
retrouve Adeline Rapon bonjour bonjour
Alors vous travaillez avec et sur les
réseaux sociaux vous êtes photographe et
influenceuse alors sur votre compte
Instagram on compte plus de 70 000
personnes qui vous suivent qui regardent
votre contenu qui parfois même le
commente vous nous expliquerez un petit
peu comment tout cela fonctionne merci à
toutes les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation enfin surtout l'invitation de
la troisième 5 du collège Louise-Michel
bonjour bonjour les élèves merci
beaucoup d'avoir travaillé sur ce
documentaire alors avec votre professeur
de français et d'histoire-géographie
vous l'avez décortiqué regardez de
nombreuses fois je sais que vous avez
énormément de questions à poser à nos
deux invités sur ce sujet mais tout
d'abord j'aimerais savoir est-ce que
parmi vous il y a des élèves des
téléphones portables combien lever la
main ceux qui ont des téléphones
portables
est-ce que vous avez des applications
dessus
quoi comme application
insta
[Musique]
Idrissa explique-moi un petit peu
qu'est-ce que tu as comme application
et YouTube après j'ai des applications
de jeux ok qu'est-ce que tu fais sur Tik
Tok je regarde tu regardes ce que les
autres font qui a Instagram
explique-moi ce que tu fais sur
Instagram j'ai des amis sur Instagram tu
les suis oui et tu suis qui d'autre les
meilleurs joueurs de foot
tu as quoi comme application sur ton
téléphone j'ai tic-tac et Instagram
qu'est-ce que tu fais sur Instagram je
regarde des influenceurs tu regardes
quoi les influenceurs c'est quoi les
influenceurs
[Musique]
est-ce que vous regardez parfois le
nombre de followers ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il y a plus de gens qui
l'aiment et toi ça t'arrive des fois de
liker
au départ c'était un
constat personnel je me suis rendu
compte que presque au matin au réveil à
mon réveil sonne j'allume mon portable
et je vais sur Instagram et là je me
suis dit c'est quand même étonnant
j'allume enfin le journal je peux
allumer la radio que ça mais je vais en
priorité sur Instagram le soir avant de
me coucher je vais sur Facebook je vais
sur les réseaux sociaux ça fait partie
de mon quotidien je me suis rendu compte
que c'était mon portable était greffé à
ma main et que très régulièrement quand
j'avais 5 minutes le réflexe était
d'aller voir ce qui se passait sur les
réseaux sociaux je me suis aussi rendu
compte
que j'avais des connaissances des amis
je savais qu'ils étaient pas forcément
très bien dans leur vie un petit
problème de coeur pour un sentimentale
problème avec les parents problèmes au
travail et qui finalement sur les
réseaux sociaux mettez en avant une vie
totalement différente
un bonheur absolu une vie avec les
copains les sorties les vacances
à se photographie en permanence je me
suis il y a quand même quelque chose
qui est étonnant en fait dans ce qu'on
fait au quotidien pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a besoin toujours de s'exhiber
et de montrer un peu son quotidien parce
que dans la vie de tous les jours très
clairement
moi ça m'est jamais arrivé d'aller à
border quelqu'un dans la rue et lui dire
regarde comme mon gâteau est beau ou
regarde mes nouvelles baskets regarde
comme mes enfants sont beaux devant la
Tour Eiffel hors sur les réseaux sociaux
ben on le fait on prend ses enfants en
photo devant la Tour Eiffel on prend ses
gâteaux en photo on prend ses boucles
d'oreilles en photo puis on attend des
autres qui réagissent qui valide cette
photo qu'il la like et qui nous disent
c'est génial c'est quand même étonnant
qu'on en arrive aujourd'hui à demander à
des gens qu'on connaît pas
ce qui pense de voilà de de son salon ou
de son chien ou de sa purée de pommes de
terre voilà c'est parti de là est-ce que
c'est la première chose que vous faites
vous en vous levant le matin regardez
votre téléphone oui
Idrissa
mon téléphone à mes messages tu regardes
si tu as des messages et toi Angel
et après je regarde les messages ok vous
avez tout de suite sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux vous allez voir s'il y a
de notification s'il y a des choses et
tout Diane tu voulais poser une question
à Adeline Rapon
est-ce que vous êtes reconnu dans le
film
oui et aussi non parce que
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait j'ai pas forcément le
même âge que les personnes qui sont
intervenues et donc moi j'ai grandi
il y avait déjà des blogs il y avait
déjà les réseaux sociaux commencer à
peine mes Facebook ça n'existait pas
Instagram ça n'existait pas et donc nous
ce qu'on avait c'était un peu comme des
journaux intimes en ligne et c'était pas
quelque chose qu'on ouvrait sur un
téléphone parce que même les téléphones
portables comme vous les connaissez
aujourd'hui avec des applications ça
n'existait pas non plus donc il fallait
qu'on aille sur l'ordinateur pour
regarder tout ça et donc
j'ai grandi sans centre me réveiller le
matin en regardant mon téléphone avec un
Internet qui voilà ce n'est pas aussi
bien que maintenant exactement
joli Facebook et tout ça ça a commencé
quand moi j'avais déjà 18 19 ans et donc
moi j'ai commencé
l'influence
que ça s'appelait pas comme ça avant
quand j'avais à peu près 18 ans et le
métier n'existait pas donc en fait moi
j'ai fait partie des premières personnes
qui ont partagé des photos comme ça sur
internet
mais c'était pas on était très peu on
était peut-être 8 je crois en France à
faire ça et après ça s'est accéléré
c'est devenu un métier et ça c'est
surtout vraiment vraiment accéléré il y
a eu de plus en plus d'influenceuses
d'influenceurs avec l'arrivée
d'Instagram notamment et puis là avec
Tik Tok en plus ça c'est encore plus
encore plus en plus grand et donc
beaucoup beaucoup de monde et beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes qui les regardent
aussi quand j'ai commencé sur mon blog
se dire que j'avais 10 000 personnes qui
venaient voir ma page tous les jours
c'était
astronomique et aujourd'hui on a des
personnes qui ont des millions et des
millions de followers qui regardent
c'est un salut le nombre et vraiment
beaucoup plus gros est-ce que ça vous
parle ça dit quand vous voyez
followers vous trouvez que c'est
beaucoup pas beaucoup vous savez ça vous
avez cet ordre cette échelle là ou pas
du tout pour moi c'est pas beaucoup ah
pour toi 10000 c'est pas beaucoup et
ouais c'est à partir de quand ça
commence à devenir beaucoup à partir
du milieu ah ouais comment avez-vous
contacté les intervenants des
documentaires a-t-il été facile pour eux
de se livrer de discuter de ces sujets
pourquoi on utilise accepté selon vous
ces quatre questions
pour les contacter les réseaux sociaux
évidemment parce que les personnages les
protagonistes que vous avez vu dans le
dans le documentaire ils sont tous
acteurs ou des réseaux sociaux soit ils
publient soit ils regardent donc pour
moi c'était évident et le plus simple
était de d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux
pour trouver les personnes qui allaient
pouvoir s'exprimer dans le documentaire
c'est super dur en fait
parce que on a juste envie c'est d'être
gentil d'avoir des amis c'est trop bête
quand on dit ça comme ça c'est vrai que
on a juste envie d'avoir des amis et
quand tu es plus jeune et que tu as zéro
mais vraiment zéro amis c'est super dur
donc évidemment j'ai envie qu'on
m'apprécie sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que c'est ce que je recherche vraiment
que qu'on me valide presque après je
crois que tu me demandais
de se livrer
on pense notamment à Marie la jeune
Marie qui parle dans le mari et puis
Andrea et Louane aussi parce que pour le
coup elle est de jeunes bien sûr non ça
a pas été facile pour elle il faut
installer une forme de climat de
confiance pour qu'une personne oublie
les caméras et finissent par te parler à
toi comme si tu étais
son ami son confident et c'est comme
dans la vie voilà c'est avant que ce
soit ton meilleur pote qui te qui va se
livrer qui va te raconter ses problèmes
bah il faut un peu de temps pour qu'elle
ait confiance en toi c'est à peu près
pareil quelles sont les difficultés que
vous avez rencontrées dans la
réalisation de ce documentaire
il y a eu deux difficultés majeures pas
pour trouver des personnes qui
utilisaient réseaux sociaux parce que
alors là
c'est un puissant fond mais pour trouver
des personnes qui allaient être honnêtes
qui allait vraiment se livrer avec
vérité parce que des personnes qui m'ont
dit ah oui j'utilise les réseaux sociaux
j'ai je voilà j'ai 100 likes par photo
où j'ai trois like ou je oui je choisis
les bons moments de ma vie j'en ai eu
plein mais qui me disent je le fais pour
recevoir la validation de ceux qui me
regardent faut être courageux quand même
pour pour l'assumer beaucoup m'ont dit
mais je le fais pour moi ben non dans ce
cas là tu prends ton album photo
personnelle tu le gardes chez toi tu
montres à tes amis mais tu l'exit pas
aux yeux de gens que tu connais pas et
la deuxième difficulté ça a été de
trouver un une personne qui allait
consulter dans des centres
d'addictologie reconnaître
qu'on a besoin d'un suivi c'est
difficile et donc forcément
accepter la présence d'une caméra est-ce
livrée devant une caméra ça ça a été ça
a été ce qui a été le plus dur à trouver
quel regard justement vous portez vous
sur les différents personnages qu'on
voit évoluer en fait dans ce
documentaire avec compassion avec
beaucoup de tristesse pour pour
plusieurs d'entre elles c'est des choses
sur lesquelles je me questionne depuis
pas mal de temps aussi sur de qu'est-ce
qu'on renvoie en fait comme l'image
qu'est-ce qu'on vend aussi
va en tant que image ou en tant que même
produit et
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que majoritairement j'ai
été un peu triste
sur votre compte Instagram vous
choisissez de publier vos photos comme
une sorte de grande exposition virtuelle
on peut voir notamment vos travaux sur
la mode bien sûr j'ai cru comprendre que
c'était par ce biais là que vous étiez
rentré d'ailleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux mais aujourd'hui on peut aussi
voir le produit de vos recherches sur
votre héritage sur la question de la
place des femmes aux Antilles il y avait
une très très belle exposition
d'ailleurs physique sur papier sur
affiche dans le dixième arrondissement
de Paris mais c'est quand même sur
Instagram que vous partagez que vous
donnez à voir votre travail pourquoi
parce que tout simplement c'est là que
j'ai construit ma communauté donc c'est
là où j'ai en fait les personnes qui
sont susceptibles de me suivre de venir
à mon exposition
qui sont présentes donc c'est
aujourd'hui c'est mon unique plateforme
réelle sur laquelle je peux réunir
autant de monde
ce qui
qui est un peu problématique
parce que c'est uniquement ça dépend
uniquement d'Instagram et Instagram
c'est c'est Facebook c'est une
entreprise c'est une entreprise privée
américaine et
en fait ce monde là si jamais Instagram
disparaît d'un seul coup et bien moi
j'ai plus personne c'est quoi le métier
d'influenceur quelqu'un serait définir
ce que ça veut dire influenceur a dit
une personne qui apparaît sur les
réseaux sociaux leur métier c'est les
réseaux sociaux et qui partagent leur un
peu leur quotidien ils montrent Jean
qu'est-ce qu'ils font
quand ils voyagent quand ils mangent
peut-être parfois
des partenariats des
partenariats
[Musique]
que c'est que le métier de
d'influenceuse
c'est c'est alors est-ce que c'est un
métier déjà c'est un métier c'est un
métier après il y a plein de formes
d'influenceurs et d'influenceuses on
appelle ça justement créateur ou
créatrice de contenu ça réunit plein de
métiers en fait en un seul et il y a le
métier de photographe de styliste de
mise en scène de vidéastes de d'édition
d'écriture
de retouche il y a aussi de la
prospection c'est à dire de chercher des
lieux de voilà il y a beaucoup
d'organisations
dans les influenceuse elles sont pas
toujours toute seule avec leur téléphone
parfois il y a des assistants qui vont
créer en fait tout un monde autour de ça
c'est un monde construit donc c'est pas
juste j'ai mon téléphone et je montre
comme ça ma vie et puis c'est fini c'est
vraiment beaucoup de travail tout autour
de ça comme vous possédez photos sur les
réseaux est-ce que vous prenez en compte
le public il va les voir si oui comment
pour moi c'est très important de faire
un contenu de faire des photographies
qui vont parler aux gens ou qui vont
faire réfléchir ce que je veux
absolument c'est aborder un sujet en
particulier ou m'adresser à une
communauté à quelqu'un voilà c'est
majoritairement c'est de raconter une
histoire y a-t-il quelqu'un qui vous a
influencé dans votre utilisation des
réseaux sociaux vous a encouragé à
devenir influenceuse moi je suis devenue
influenceuse par accident
parce que justement comme je vous l'ai
dit j'ai commencé avant que le métier
existe
ensuite oui moi j'ai eu beaucoup
d'influence par toutes les personnes qui
m'ont entouré qui ont commencé en même
temps que moi ou après aussi ça m'a
permis moi de savoir ce que je voulais
faire et comment je voulais le faire
c'est à dire que par exemple j'ai deux
utilisations de réseaux sociaux j'ai mon
utilisation qui est très intime très
personnel je ne vais pas montrer où
j'habite je vais pas montrer où je suis
à l'instant T
parce que je tiens à préserver une sorte
de sécurité parce qu'on sait pas qui
regarde nos réseaux sociaux donc c'est
j'ai appris tout ça c'était pas immédiat
au début parce qu'au début on utilisait
internet un peu n'importe comment mais
maintenant je fais très attention à ce
que je montre donc je crée un cadre très
précis et ça justement parce qu'il y a
eu différentes histoires qui je suis
arrivé par le passé à différentes
personnes Amel pour vous c'est quoi la
beauté pouvez-vous nous donner votre
définition de ce concept
la beauté c'est c'est
flou on sépare et puis la beauté ça
dépend en fait de qui qui la regarde et
ce que j'aime faire c'est montrer la
beauté partout c'est à dire que quand je
prends des photos
je veux absolument que tout le monde
trouve ça beau peu importe ce que je
vais montrer je veux que les gens
trouvent ça beau mais la beauté enfin je
vais te poser la même question tu vas
pas savoir me dire
[Rires]
tu voulais poser une question à Elisa
Jadot à votre avis et d'après votre
travail pourquoi les jeunes ont tant
besoin d'être présent sur les réseaux
sociaux et de poster des photos de même
ou de leur vie
déjà tout simplement parce que les
jeunes votent génération et la
génération encore d'après est né avec
les réseaux sociaux donc de toute façon
c'est reste en fait on vous l'a mis dans
la main je vois pas comment vous
pourriez aujourd'hui vivre sans puisque
vous voilà vous avez grandi avec après
alors c'est pas moi qui le dit mais
c'est les
psychothérapeutes les psychi ceux qui
connaissent bien le milieu adolescent
qui explique que c'est une période quand
même où on est en construction
c'est une période où on a besoin de
reconnaissance on essaie de se
construire une personnalité en dehors du
regard de nos parents et donc on essaye
d'aller chercher l'approbation dans le
regard des autres donc de ses camarades
de ses profs et donc sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est décuplé parce qu'on va
aller chercher le regard de personne
même qu'on connaît pas donc ce besoin
d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux
d'exposer sa vie c'est une façon de
se rassurer en fait sur qui on est sur
est-ce que ce qu'on fait c'est bien tu
avais une question aussi toi pour Elisa
Jadot pour nous passer beaucoup de temps
sur les écrans et normal mais vous
constant c'est vous
ce qui me semble important c'est savoir
ce qu'on regarde et comment on
comment réagit face aux réseaux sociaux
est-ce qu'on a envie de ressembler à ce
qu'on voit est-ce qu'on a du recul
vis-à-vis de ça est-ce que ça nous amuse
je pense pas qu'il y a normal pas normal
parce qu'il y a de très bons côtés aussi
dans les réseaux sociaux ça permet de
mettre en avant beaucoup d'artistes de
créateurs de contenu
de dénoncer bien sûr mais il y a ce côté
pervers il faut faire hyper attention
surtout quand on est jeune et vraiment
prendre conscience pourquoi on regarde
pourquoi on poste
est-ce que ça voilà ce que ce que ça
nous fait est-ce que ça nous rend
heureux vraiment ou est-ce que parfois
ça peut ça peut nous chagriner
[Musique]
le fait de liker et bien activer des
régions cérébrales et notamment celles
qui sont impliquées dans le circuit
cérébral de la récompense qui est
vraiment le circuit clé qui joue un rôle
dans les addictions donc être sur les
réseaux liker ou savoir qu'on like ces
images ou même liker les images des
autres ça active les centres du plaisir
ça procure du plaisir et donc on
comprend mieux pourquoi ça donne envie
d'y retourner de répéter ce comportement
est-ce que parmi
vous comme addict
vraiment qui se disent oh là là j'ai pas
eu mon téléphone pendant 24 heures faut
absolument que je regarde ce qui s'est
passé Imran toi tu es pas bien si jamais
si jamais tu as pas eu ton téléphone
pendant je sais pas deux jours par
exemple c'est possible pour toi de pas
avoir ton téléphone pendant deux jours
comme ça avec la tête tu combien de
temps tu peux tenir sans ton téléphone
5 minutes c'est vrai
tu as besoin tu as besoin d'aller voir
ce qui se passe
je sais pas il est obligé de rester dans
ma main ok qu'est-ce que disent vos
parents ma mère des fois elle me dit
laisse un peu ton téléphone ou mes
tantes ma mère elle veut te casser mon
téléphone elle a cassé ton téléphone
elle veut elle veut qu'elle sait ton
téléphone ah oui tu comprends pourquoi
elle réagit comme ça ou pas
pour les yeux aussi tu penses qu'à la
raison oui à partir de quel moment
peut-on dire que nous subissons une
addiction aux écrans aux réseaux sociaux
y a-t-il des critères précis il y a
différentes échelles on n'est pas tous
addict de la même manière mais quoi
qu'il en soit à partir du moment où on
peut pas se passer de son téléphone plus
de 55 minutes et encore ça va 55 minutes
parce que c'est le temps de j'imagine du
cours
mais si on n'arrive pas à le laisser de
côté si on a tout le temps besoin d'y
aller si on a ce réflexe d'aller voir
ce qu'on a loupé qu'on n'arrive pas à
s'en détacher je pense que là on peut
oui se considérer comme comme addict
aux réseaux sociaux oui complètement
ouais ouais je pense que j'ai pas un
seul jour où je regarde pas les réseaux
sociaux donc oui
pour passer moi de temps de vous les
écrans
c'est quoi votre truc sortir vous sortir
oui la stratégie
déjà peut-être essayer de peut-être un
peu dur mais de se forcer à y passer
moins de temps c'est se dire bon le
matin je vais pas y aller tout de suite
je vais quand même attendre d'avoir pris
ma douche pris mon petit déjeuner puis
je vais je vais aller voir regardez
quand vous êtes sur les sur les
téléphones quand on est sur les
téléphones je crois que de vous non
c'est pareil on est là comme ça avec
notre truc et notre doigt et en swip
pour machin et puis il y a rien qui
existe oui dans notre bulle il y a rien
qui existe mais c'est terrible
regardez la personne à côté de vous
enfin il y a de quoi rire se dire mais
c'est pas possible c'est un truc qui
fait que on est dans la peau de d'un
enfant de 3 ans qui demande à son papa
et à sa maman si on est beau ou bien
nous papa maman qui disons mais
qu'est-ce que tu es beau voilà c'est
hyper régressif alors que essayons de
produire du contenu produire autre chose
pour pas qu'on nous dise bah tu es beau
mais plutôt ce que tu fais c'est bien je
suis intéressé parce que tu fais devenir
quelqu'un au-delà de du physique notre
cerveau est beaucoup moins créatif
qu'avant on écrit beaucoup moins bien
il est en permanence alimentée d'image
on n'arrive plus à regarder quelque
chose sans sans juste reconnaître la
beauté d'un paysage plus de 3 secondes
donc voilà essayons de je pense de petit
à petit quotidiennement
de faire autre chose et d'essayer de
réagir autrement au moins essayer voilà
pour nous garder fidèle les algorithmes
analysent nos goûts répondent à nos
désirs ils anticipent nos réactions
en collectant nos clics nos like nos
publications ils nous connaissent
parfois mieux que nous-mêmes rien n'est
dû au hasard
l'algorithme surpuissant qui apprend à
exploiter nos vulnérabilités
que les algorithmes veulent à tout prix
nous contrôler notre circulation sur les
réseaux sociaux comment peut-on lutter
contre cela c'est pas facile parce que
les algorithmes c'est c'est construit
c'est une série de numéros c'est un truc
hyper compliqué construit par des génies
de l'informatique et je pense que c'est
très difficile de lutter contre les
algorithmes c'est très très bien conçu
c'est à nous en fait de prendre le
dessus et de d'essayer de ne pas
s'enfermer dans la bulle
imposé par par les algorithmes après
avoir regardé votre documentaire je me
demande combien de temps met
l'algorithme pour définir mes centres
d'intérêt et me proposer du contenu
dirigé en quelques secondes ouais en
quelque secondes
le seul moment où
l'algorithme de connaît pas c'est quand
aucun réseau social donc tu vas te tu
vas entrer ton nom et encore tu vas
entrer ton âge il va tout de suite te
cibler à te proposer du contenu qui
pourrait éventuellement t'intéresser
est-ce que Adeline Rapon vous diriez que
votre patron aujourd'hui c'est
l'algorithme complètement donc moi je
travaille sur Instagram donc ça veut
dire que je publie mes photos sur
Instagram j'ai des échanges sur
Instagram je reçois des messages sur
Instagram j'ai du monde sur Instagram je
peux faire des partenariats sur
Instagram mais là ça va être les
partenariats ce sont les marques qui
vont me payer moi en fait là mon patron
c'est Instagram mais il me paye pas
Instagram parce que moi je voilà tout ce
que je fais c'est que je donne du
contenu et puis derrière
Instagram il se fait de l'argent parce
que vous vous venez parce que vous venez
regarder nos photos et ça c'est le
principe de tous les réseaux sociaux au
final parce que si il y a personne sur
les réseaux sociaux qui sont en train de
fournir du travail ou du contenu
gratuitement et ben en fait les réseaux
sociaux ils existent plus est-ce que
vous trouvez pas ça juste qui vous paye
pas oui j'aimerais bien qu'il
en fait non enfin effectivement je
trouve que c'est pas très juste de ne
pas pouvoir être rémunéré ou en tout cas
que les personnes qui me suivent
puissent me soutenir financièrement donc
me donner des petits euros comme ça par
ci par là pour me soutenir ça pour le
coup il y a des plateformes qui le
proposent TikTok ils le font par exemple
YouTube aussi quand on publie des vidéos
on peut être rémunéré par YouTube parce
qu'il y a les publicités etc donc
Instagram spécifiquement effectivement
ne le fait pas mais j'aimerais bien
j'ai une question pour vous et
avec certaines de mes camarades nous
pensons que l'âge limitait à 13 ans
n'est pas forcément adapté pour
fréquenter les réseaux sociaux qu'en
pensez-vous je pense que vous avez
raison il y a déjà un âge limite mais
qui est pas respecté on voit beaucoup de
jeunes sur TikTok ont déjà dit 100 ans
même dans le documentaire la petite sœur
de Louane à 11 ans elle est déjà sur sur
Tik Tok
pas simple pour les parents de donner
les bonnes armes à leurs enfants quand
dès l'âge de 11 ans plus de la moitié
d'entre eux est déjà connecté au réseau
sociaux
oui mais évidemment il faudrait un âge
limite parce que ce qu'on voit sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est pas uniquement des
jolies photos de paysage ou des photos
engagés ou il y a des contenus qui sont
hyper sexualisés et à 13 ans ou à 10 ans
ou à 11 ans on n'est pas préparé à avoir
des femmes ou des hommes
en sous-vêtements à quatre pattes enfin
voilà c'est des choses qui sont pas
enfin honnêtement moi j'aurais pas envie
que mes enfants à 11 ans soient
voilà soit face à ce genre de contenu il
y en a de plus en plus à 13 ans on est
un enfant puis faut pas oublier aussi
qu'il y a des quand même des personnes
qui traînent sur les réseaux sociaux qui
qui voilà qui qui sont pas très
recommandables on sait pas qu'il y a en
face donc qui peut vous mauvaise
intentions quoi ouais donc oui 13 ans
c'est très jeune pour avoir conscience
de ce que sont les réseaux sociaux ce
bonheur parfait ou cette vie parfaite
affichée par des influenceurs
c'est pas la vraie vie bah oui
s'engueule avec leur compagnon oui ils
ont des enfants qui crient et qui se
vomissent dessus oui ils ont des chiens
qu'on bouffait le canapé donc la vraie
vie la vie réelle n'est pas celle qui
est exhibée sur les réseaux sociaux et
je suis pas certaine qu'à 13 ans et même
plutôt on est conscience de ça shainez
tu avais une question selon nous comment
pourrait-on protéger les plus jeunes de
l'exposition réseaux sociaux je trouve
que ce qui est dangereux beaucoup dans
dans l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
des jeunes c'est que vous le faites en
privé sur un petit écran et que c'est
pas comme à l'époque où il y avait juste
la télé et du coup quand un parent passé
on pouvait voir ce qui se passait et
parler de s'il y avait s'il y a une
image choquante il y a quelque chose
d'un peu inquiétant ou on a besoin d'en
parler
ça pouvait se faire comme ça et là le
fait que ce soit privé que ce soit dans
votre petit coin
moi c'est la chose que je trouve assez
assez effrayante quand il y avait la
télé au milieu du salon nous on a connu
que ça on regardait les dessins animés
après l'école ou les petites séries ou
le week-end mais c'était au milieu du
salon les parents étaient à côté il y
avait un contrôle parental et puis
d'ailleurs avant d'avoir un contrôle
parental les chaînes de télé diffusaient
pas n'importe quoi sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a pas de contrôle tout le
monde peut poster presque n'importe quoi
donc et pour les parents je pensais très
difficile de de d'être sûr de ce que nos
enfants regardent choumicha qui avait
aussi une question pour adulte avez-vous
déjà reçu des critiques ou des
commentaires haineux ou subit de
harcèlement si oui pouvez-vous nous
expliquer pourquoi
oui alors je n'ai pas été harcelé à
proprement parler j'ai déjà eu des
commentaires qui me critiquaient sur mon
physique
et qui ont créé des complexes que je
n'aurais jamais je n'aurais jamais
jamais pensé à ça si en fait quelqu'un
n'avait pas écrit derrière son
ordinateur à ma chambre et aujourd'hui
ça va mieux j'ai grandi depuis mais
c'est vrai que ça pub énormément blesser
parce que d'un seul coup on se voit à
travers un regard qui est foncièrement
méchant et
et qui en plus est anonyme on sait pas
qui nous parle on sait pas d'où on sait
pas pourquoi non plus c'est très violent
d'un seul coup parce que ça sort de
nulle part et on le lit on l'entend et
on est complètement dans un autre dans
une autre sphère et le harcèlement ça
peut arriver aussi très vite il y a pas
que les influenceuses parce qu'il peut y
avoir toutes les personnes qui peuvent
se retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux qui
peuvent un jour se retrouver au centre
dans harcèlement c'est vrai que c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est très
effrayant ça vous avez déjà lu vous des
commentaires haineux sur les réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]
qui est une prise de conscience
de la part des jeunes la part des
parents des intervenants à l'école et
qu'on essaye de comprendre que les
réseaux sociaux ils ont été créés pour
combler un manque qu'on a qui est existé
dans le regard des autres à partir du
moment où on a tous compris ça on peut
éviter de tomber dans le piège voilà et
je suis pas certaine que les réseaux
sociaux nous rendent tout le temps
heureux ils sont très asociaux en fait
parce qu'on est tout seul devant son
écran ils peuvent même nous rendre
malheureux voilà le but était de
d'expliquer ça et qu'on prenne tout ce
conscience de ça voilà on va s'arrêter
là l'émission est déjà terminée merci
merci beaucoup à toutes les deux merci
de nos deux invités Elisa Jadot et Aline
répond d'avoir participé à Z la Zone
d'Éducation en documentaire et puis
merci à vous les élèves bravo vous
pouvez vous applaudir bravo vous avez
payé des super questions c'est vraiment
super intéressant j'espère que ça vous a
plu et puis merci évidemment à vos deux
professeurs
d'histoire-géographie et de français et
puis
bien vous devant votre écran n'hésitez
pas évidemment à commenter aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux sur Instagram sur la
page Instagram de la Chaîne
Parlementaire vous pouvez aussi m'écrire
un mail j'y répondrai évidemment Z
revient très vite avec une nouvelle
classe et un nouveau documentaire parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour questionner
le monde et ces images allez salut les
enfants salut
[Musique]